so you
[Music]
can perfect
perfect yo
what's going on guys welcome back to the
dope as usual podcast
i am thomas dobergiolo whatever you want
to call me i'm here with marty o'neil
drastic graphics what's up folks what's
up
what's up it's the last episode no no
it's the first episode of the year sorry
it's the last we're filming this on new
year's eve but this is coming out you
know what first week of january
mario let's start this strong let's get
this going for everyone out there that
just made a new year's resolution
drop that [__] you're not going to
follow through with it make one with us
now make something feasible something
that you can actually obtain within
these first couple months because that's
when people just give up
you know what my new year's resolutions
are no
ready
unless it's like a protein bar or
something i'm not eating anything out of
a package anymore
i have to not be a fat person anymore
bro i mean i'm i do good stuff because
vegan i eat well
but i'm over eating breads a lot you
know i mean eating wraps and like bro
i gotta start cooking everything at my
house
or get it you know what i'm saying like
so my new year's resolution not eat
anything out of a package
trying to eat a bunch of fruits and
vegetables and make my own stuff you
know what i'm saying stay on the
perimeter of that goddamn grocery store
exactly well i do dude i mean
i'm fat but i i eat relatively good i
just
you guys eat healthy as [__] yeah i just
eat a lot of breads and that's really
what [__] me up anyway sorry for i got
cussed right off the bat
[__] here we go
real new year's resolution that and my
fina
my life new year's resolution the health
one was just because i need to fix this
ready you ready this might help some of
you guys
i am no longer going to hang out ever
again unless we talk about something
productive or business at least one time
while chilling don't come over my house
anymore just take dabs cover my house
take dabs also let's be productive and
think of something something we have to
do one thing
i don't chill a lot
when i'm sitting there i'm like
oh you know what stuff i gotta edit oh i
can't just why am i sitting here but
then i can never hang out i never hang
out then if i don't
i hear i haven't [__] hung out in
like nine years that's how i feel you
know i mean just
if i do hang out like yo i am wasting my
time
why am i here
there's so much stuff to be paid for
there's so much stuff to edit it's way
worse when you have kids too dude i can
it's this it's a stress constant stress
of why am i saying that's why i'm
playing games
like because i'm playing games like yo i
could just be editing with his hands
what am i doing this for does that help
me tomorrow
playing games is a goal to me yes i want
to be able to i would love to play video
games thank you i would love to sit down
and go no no i got the time yeah don't
worry like let's let's chill let's play
games i don't have the time
so that's my other resolution is to
never waste my time again basically it's
just if i'm hanging out with people it's
great
we got to do something
something has to happen in that session
hanging out i know i used to even like
back in the day like when we were so
deep into music
it's easy to get caught up in that yeah
i'll come over we'll write yeah we'll
record yeah then it's like four hours
nothing really and you write one
meaningful transpired and we're just
where we were before we [__] started
exactly i didn't know a lot of you went
yup
that's me that's me and my friend dude
that was me until today
[Laughter]
you know me if i do have time to hang
out sit there like yo we just watched
youtube for two hours
what did i do myself and i mean that's
great hang out have you have fun just
i can't do it no more man i've done it
long enough since i was 15. yeah
yeah that's how i feel the your time to
hang out is when you're a [__] kid
yeah now i'm now i'm just like yo let's
hang out but like in our new house
i'm trying to get that house let's work
until we get there
that's all marty i'm trying to be
productive i'm trying to be an adult i'm
trying to go
but why are you fat
fix it like i get it like working out
was on it for so long and now i'm like a
third as much as i was but we've been
super busy new companies just dropped i
get it
i've just been so busy man
it's just
anyway new year's resolution set one
that's feasible sense something that's
small like i would lose a hundred pounds
like bro come on
say you want to lose 20 by the summer
because then you're going to hit 40 by
the summer and go oh [__] you know what
i'm saying set small goals enough that
you can actually obtain them hell yeah
that's a huge piece of advice
[__] no you're not some you're gonna be
sick for three days this year
just say you're gonna go
every time you're gonna watch some tv
and [__] go to the gym and then come
back watch tv
i don't know they're like corniest
advice i ever heard about that is like
if you want to build a brick wall lay a
brick every day it's so true
it's the simplest thing yeah building a
brick wall is a massive [__] thing
it's gonna take a ton of time and effort
but as long as you lay a brick a day
eventually there will be a [__] wall
it's a great way to put it yeah it's
true it's with everything will smith
big willy style aren't you
wait was it an interview yeah or some
[__] his dad told him i think i could be
butchering this in my mind that was
wilson's dad
[Music]
his advice was work yeah just work just
real obvious [__]
it's true though it's true so i just
want to say that i've seen comments
after this whole year
it's the last day of the year for us and
i know it's like january 3rd or
something in posting time but
i've gotten thousands this year how many
comments we get 44 000 comments this
year
on youtube yep we've answered back about
38 of them
yeah pretty [__] close pretty close
yeah i mean after it gets about a
thousand two thousand i just kind of
give up
i've seen so many people in there like
yo the advice you guys drop on this is
helping me with my life oh yeah
i i forget you know think about back
when you were younger or even if
someone's our age
if you've never had anybody explain
something to you your brain might have
not saw it totally you know that's why
two brains is better than one like on
the same project maybe they see
something you don't because your brain
doesn't work that way
so maybe our brains work this way and
it's simpler to
understand because we're already coming
to watches
so i think
this year
we've helped a lot of people just
motivate themselves and try to do
something else i've seen a lot of people
i started the business yeah watching the
show
i've just tried and now it's working
exactly exactly it might not always work
but when it does
[__] bomb
you know like super cool so this is the
last episode of the years wanted to say
that the motivational thing new year's
resolution set something small something
you can obtain and who cares if you have
five this year because you knocked out
four
and next year maybe you'll be like you
know what i think i can do that full
year now just don't make yourself upset
before you could even get started
because people say i gotta lose 100
pounds like [__] how about like three
this week
[Music]
let's try to keep it like kind of
consistent and realistic that's all
so let's get off that [__] top
i don't even know how he got on that
topic why did he talk about that man
because it's [__] new years oh
yeah it's new year's i'm bert yeah it's
new year's i love this [__] though i
just love this statement this past year
of us being like
[__]
let us just [__] do this [__]
ourselves
and then do it and then have it work
that's just a statement like
read more you just came out
yeah i love that though like
just two-man operation the black sheep
of [__] youtube doesn't [__]
matter
stolen out of our goddamn minds shadow
ban us to death that's whatever like the
community's too strong yeah oh that's
what we're going on because we got we
just hit 10 million views on this
channel while being shadow band uh age
restricted
[__] on which is cool
[__] you still hit 10 million views in
our first 10 months
cool super sick
318 million watch time minutes
try to wrap your mind around that it's
730 years yep
yep we do i went all the way back in
that math last night i was like how many
lifetimes is this
yo what
you have seven healthy older asian
japanese men's life
our watch just little 110 goes back to
the [__] caveman damn near
300. i don't know that was an ignorant
ass statement it does i mean
it goes
700 some odd years right now give us
until next season we're going back to
the [__] caveman
since [__] didn't even have
rights all right we've you guys been
watching it's crazy 318 million watch
time minutes that's how long you guys
have heard and watched our stupid faces
say and then
so thank you guys so much 318 million
watch time minutes which is unfucking
believable thank you guys
that's this year wrapped up all right
and the clips channel what was that like
four or five million views that's right
up there
let's write the [__] up there that's
just doing great watching that clips
channel supports just as much as that
main channel let that [__] crazy so
thank you guys just want to say thank
you this is the year wrap-up
year wrap up video real quick let me
recap on last week
all right let me recap on last week's
episode the mushroom episode let me tell
you guys what happened
all right mushrooms hit me harder than i
thought remember i take about seven
grams each time uh you guys thought i
was kind of [__] up you should see me
on seven grams i'm swimming on the table
just like ripping my shirt i'm just gone
right
so marty did the ad reach which is
hilarious i could not do it i just
couldn't hold it together
i don't know how i did the my bookie ad
[__]
fully gone guys at the end we did my
bookie
allegedly yeah that [__] was like
so [__] funny to have you beep in
early in the episode just so stone-faced
keeping it together i kept it together
well you couldn't even look like yeah it
looked like continuous like let's just
do this head right now
boys swimming in the multiverse son
so what happened is i marty drove me
home we almost hit this grown man
running across the street remember and i
went
this mushrooms gave me spider sense
i don't know if we almost hit him or if
he almost got killed okay this man you
know when cars are parked and you're
coming up on the turns you can't see if
someone's you know buying a taller car
full-grown man decides to sprint from
behind the car across the street and i
just went
toby maguire hit
morty what y'all and marty just ah the
guy
with his [__] button-up sweater oh
almost died and then he dropped me off
and then i proceeded
no time at all guys i had to you know in
mushrooms when you're like no no no
just go lay down just be by yourself
just go
my brain just i couldn't wait to get
home and just like i got to go by myself
i got to be myself
i get in my bed rosie was gone for like
three hours when i got home so i was by
myself
and i wrapped myself in my blanket and
only this cup un uncovered you guys know
that
i wrapped the whole thing around my
whole body
i was laying in my bed
and i just watched seinfeld for like
three hours straight in a fun way though
dying laughing yeah yeah
yo i felt so [__] funny and i'm
sitting there just
shrinkage
yeah shrinkage i'm just like
i'm just watching episodes and the
episode they get stuck in the parking
garage and like
getting like a slight panic attack for
something oh my god they can't get out
and they're like oh your mushroom's full
chill out you're at home and i'm just
sitting there and i did nothing didn't
move didn't look at my phone i did
nothing
nice it was so fun for about three and a
half hours
rosie got home and i fell asleep for
like an hour
and you know when you come off a
mushroom trip it's like a whole nother
life it's like everything restarted
but i fell asleep when i restarted so i
woke up feeling weird
[Music]
that was it yeah but that's what
happened after that episode like three
hours just fully peaked guns it was an
all-day affair right i could still see
it in your eyes when you called me later
yeah would you call me later on yeah i
was definitely just
not tripping i just saw tracers and
everything was breathing i didn't start
hallucinating like normal like normal
i'll [__] trip out but anyway just
wanted to talk about last week's episode
in case you're like what happened after
that's what happened also quick update
we talked about the truck driver last
week
[__] just got a sentence reduced
yesterday
and how crazy is it that i'm like
oh he should have got more time even
though i'm the one like he got way too
much time and now i'm like wait
he only gave him 10 years
after all this mean bitching like i
thought he was gonna be like 20. that's
justified five years of life
a death
i'd be so [__] mad if that was my
family but yet two and a half years hmm
110's too much but two and a half i'm
over here just like can i have it my way
like a [__] [__] but no you got 10
years from 110 to reduce to 10. you see
his mug shot
from 110 to 10
oh you can see his life is back he's
like
give me 10 years that's sad like rick
ross i'll take the 20. please please
give me 20. yeah yeah like no dude
he got 10 but it's like that's not a lot
of time for killing four people but holy
[__] at least it wasn't 110.
you'd rather have the 10 than one time
it's not even my life and death i mean
life and death it's just sad but anyway
they
reduced it very cool super cool
controversial topic controversial topic
on to my next controversial topic we're
not scared of these goddamn
controversial topics you ready i got
hundreds of people you stick to the weed
bro i don't want to [__] hear you
talking about this and then don't watch
the point of the goddamn podcast then
don't watch when i started off i start
remember last week i started off before
i talk about this topic remember i don't
give a [__] about your opinion don't
waste your time nobody gives a [__] and
no none of you listened
i've been talk i've been like just
remember guys if you have a different
opinion to me that's fine i i'm not
going to get mad at you
you know i
house whatever everybody's just talking
[__] to me a lot of people talking [__]
like you don't even know all the facts
you shouldn't speak
i don't need to know all the [__]
facts you know he had a medic bag on you
didn't even mention that like oh no it
matters you know he killed a pedophile
right oh he knew the criminal history
before he shot him so that's what you're
telling me he knew the criminals before
he shot him so he's actually a vigilante
what you just said contradicts
everything you just said
what anyway guys
please
stop wasting your time i don't [__]
care about your opinion
i truly don't you guys come on man
there's so many comments on this clip
that we did on the clip channel like
i think people think that other fools
care that much about what they have to
say
this is a show
all right i'm just gonna talk if you
don't like it you don't gotta watch
that's [__] it
that's all i gotta say about that
there's nothing else to say
don't look then
you look at the person that don't
[__] care about your opinion even a
little bit well i mean yeah i mean the
show's about your perspective on things
perspective yeah and our opinion if my
opinion differs from yours that's okay
i see your side and i see my side the
difference between me and you is you're
biased i'm not
we don't see both sides value
everybody's opinion oh that's what i
mean like
i i don't care about your opinion when
it's coming at me yeah
when you're coming at me with your
opinion like oh [__] i don't give a
[__] what you got to say about your
thoughts i don't give a [__]
that's all i i i just really need to
really reiterate that to you guys
don't waste your time if you watch the
show
you know i don't give a [__] right
i'm allowed to have an opinion sorry
that's all i want to cut to that juice
scene so bad oh yeah give a [__]
yeah dude that's how i feel like
i don't give a [__]
people like you should cause the thing i
kept getting you don't know all the
facts you need to shut the [__] up like
i don't need to know all the facts
somebody shot somebody that shouldn't
have been there he shouldn't have been
attacked for having a gun
case closed
self-defense shouldn't have been there
though it's kind of enticing people but
that's not illegal
yeah you don't gotta be close you don't
kind of like
there's gonna be horrible tragedies that
come up in life and not everybody's
gonna agree yeah and like we gotta speak
on them sometimes like as a community a
show like
it's not the whole focus of the show is
this [__] but once in a while we'll
sprinkle them in
and this you can't please everybody some
people are mad at me for talking about
it some people are mad at me for not
bringing up topics yeah
and a lot of people related to it and
we're happy about it both of you can
[__] off on either side because you
don't have to watch the show
you just unfollow the [__]
it's quick
easy just one button
it's a touch screen
it's not even a big deal
so um i think what it is is uh everybody
wants to be like a justice vigilante
warrior like yo no i spoke up against
like spoke up guy doesn't remember your
name nobody gives a [__]
that's really what it is i think people
with social media were like yo i have a
platform and a voice but
not really i'll just scroll past i don't
care yeah i mean
the comments are comments are for
everybody's opinion it's a lot you're
allowed to have an opinion of course
different when you're doing it in like a
condescending way to be shitty yeah like
you're a piece of [__] you don't even
know all the [__] facts like hold on
stop
are you a lawyer then you don't know all
the facts i watched the case oh so
you're a lawyer in the courtroom you
know everything
for sure
you waste your time on the internet
talking to somebody
good job you passed the bar for this oh
no you didn't oh shut the [__] up you're
as educated as me
[Laughter]
you're never going to win for me you're
never going to win because why i'm
logical unbiased
i'm logical and unbiased means
you can't play me we assume most [__] is
kind of [__] up and corrupt and wrong
and backwards too so i was like yeah
but yeah that's i just want to talk
about that guys real quick and then a
lot of you like i don't i come here to
escape from the politics
well and skip this part
it's like this like yo i love this house
i love it this light switch doesn't work
i'm moving
well how about you just don't look at
the light switch yeah
yeah it's okay to take the [__] around
95 percent of the time and talk about
sometimes we talk about [__] because you
know what's in the earth
yeah
can't rain all the time anyway what time
we at
20.
all right here we go light this
[__] i just want to rehash on
that just in case you guys thought i
cared
um stop wait
stop wasting your time
it's annoying for me to copy and paste
my same [__]
i copy and paste my rebuttals to the
people that are rude because they're
always making the same statement so can
i
[Music]
i mean
i don't know i put things pretty clearly
pretty clear-cut
uh
there's no hidden agendas and he's just
there
okay here we go
also real quick drop in the comments
what other podcasts do you guys watch i
want to see some podcasts i feel like
i don't want to watch comedians podcasts
because they're on like episode 190 or
which is cool
i want to see like what's the uh what
are all the people doing i just listened
to so many podcasts i used to listen to
podcast all day long
i really don't as i mean i'm so in the
mix of it i don't as much now i would
love some new things to listen to yeah
yeah you're busy man the only time i
have stuffed time to listen to anything
is when i drive up here
really yeah because you figure if i'm
editing if you're editing video you
can't listen to other [__] that's why i
don't listen to music that much less i'm
in the car yeah exactly
yeah please yeah drop some comments i
see a lot of people say misfits
i don't know who that is but i see a lot
of people saying the misfits drop in the
comments who do you want us to
talk to
you know
who wants to talk i figure in the weed
war in the podcast world
we're kind of like the kids your parents
told like don't hang out with those kids
that's how i feel my whole life
so i've always felt like a
like oh [__] i've always felt like that
man especially when it comes to this
weed [__] like when i go to parties
you don't even know i'm there
i don't want to talk to them
like
um
it's not just because i'm getting sick
i'm saying like
i'm just not that person i've never been
like that like the super what up
and
it's just not not me
sometimes depending on what environment
from with my friends that's different
we're all
all like that but
i don't know how i got on this topic
marty i'm not sure i don't know either
we're diving deep introspective wow
so yeah i don't remember how i got on
the topic but
yeah how the [__] did i get on this who
cares
all right about that
let's get off the topic oh it's talking
about parties or something dumb oh yeah
so drop some comments who do you guys
new podcasts podcast there we go
my brain
it's everywhere
so real quick right after this episode
second we're done i'm driving straight
to big bear i've never been
i've been to the snow like one or two
times in my life never stayed in a cabin
uh
here we go all right the house we're
standing is on the htv hgtv house like
the big house that says yeah rosiers are
showing it to me this [__] is sick
have you driven through bad snow before
yeah once not personally but only once
i've only driven into snow one time
actually if we get on a cliff edge and
it's scary i'm driving back to yeah
going up there that is what big bear is
you're winding up a [__] mountain
near the top that's fine that's fine
we're at the base
i'm not going to the top
[__]
did i
did i tell you what happened last time
we went to big bear the [__] horror
story you didn't go you said no last
time we went oh because marty was
supposed to go last thursday yeah
because it snowed in they're not going
we're gonna go for so what happened last
time
we get there we let the kids [__] we get
there you know it's like sun's about to
go down it's kind of late let's say it's
friday [__] night we let the kids do
a little light sledding in the back
they come in they have some hot
chocolate
4am rolls around my daughter starts
[__] puking everywhere she's still
puking to the morning i go to get her
medicine in the morning at like rite aid
or some [__] and they're like you know a
big ass storm is coming right like if
you guys are planning on getting out of
here at all for the next couple of days
you better
yeah so
i'm like oh okay there's a giant
blizzard coming we're gonna be snowed in
we got a sick kid great so we just leave
that like we leave
then so we're out the door and this
[__] storm is starting to come down
this blizzard on top of this giant
mountain
so now she's in the back seat puking
puking into a bag
we start we're like kind of trying to
outrun this blizzard down this like the
cliff edge of a mountain if you've been
on these mountains it's like before your
[__] is [__] intense you're real
white
you're the weirdest guy i've ever heard
you went out in a [__] natural
disaster off a mountain with all your
family keep going people yeah it's like
we're trying to avoid the disaster
hunters tornado chasing something like
that that's what it felt like you got a
kid
waiting it out for a couple days wasn't
an option
all right so you're out running a storm
yeah your name is [__]
daniel danny or what's his name randy
quaid the [__] actor
where's
so anyway
puking puking
now all of a sudden from the back seat
now the diarrhea starts coming bam
little shot of diarrhea okay
back seat so now we're pulled over
on the side of the [__] cliff
we're throwing clothes over the [__]
edge i'm puking i'm i got hurt puke
there's diarrhea in the mix now i'm
[__] puking and dry even off the edge
of the cliff
i'm throwing clothes over the edge of
the cliff
the storms come in we're getting our
[__] together we get back in the car we
continue down the [__] cliff
we're going down the cliff maybe another
couple minutes cam starts [__] puking
in the back seat now because of the
smell so now they're both puking
pull back over again same [__] i started
puking april's screaming at me
throwing clothes off the cliff like
cam's back there like without a shirt on
now other it's [__] winter time
uh
so that happened i think three times
total until we made it to the bottom of
the [__] cliff where we pulled over
with [__] [__] and puke everywhere
and then we went straight to the
hospital
yo i'm sorry that's so [__] [__] that
sucks so much all i got from that was
marty throws any shitty pants you find
and big bears remark
that's all i heard you happen to be in
the [__] bottom of the [__] cliff
that's where i'm at
[__] pants on my [__] building watch
so yeah we've had a couple trips like
that
i drove through i got snowed in the
blizzard in denver i was there for four
days in the cabin
with
my friend
and uh he
is like a famous hashmaker
you guys ever heard of maguido
yeah true
maguino
we had snowden at his house in denver
he's got the biggest class collection
i'm probably on the planet
he's got an eagle like a bird like four
feet tall and it's a rig it sits in his
kitchen up top like a statue but it's a
rig
he has one room marty the size of this
room that's full a big giant tupperware
big buckets of alcohol
and there's just big pieces sitting in
the mall jesus he cleans his class so
meticulously
there was bombs as big as this table
rigs just functions like like like like
a hot wheel track style things
but
he's a hashmaker he probably had five
pounds of hash in his house
we
put movies on with no sound and he
played
albums
and we dabbed for four days
straight
straight all the way through
non-stop damn it was wild actually
there's a store or nothing
was it awesome it was [__] awesome
we sat in there for four we just went to
his house
we only met once went to his house to
hang out for a couple hours
that's it he goes you guys just stay
here it's coming to me like it's kind of
storm like
all right well that's cool woke up he
goes
bro it's a blizzard i just talked to i
just i saw the radio like it's gonna be
like a daze
don't worry there's enough there's no
you just let us stay in here this is odd
imagine getting trapped in school like
that that happens that's scary i'd be so
pissed on the school bus
that's a movie no thank you
imagine flying into a city imagine
flying from california into buffalo and
like you're wearing shorts and a hoodie
because it's like kind of warm here and
you get there and it's winter and you
you get a get in a rental car you get on
the freeway and the snow starts coming
down so hard so fast that it buries you
on the freeway did you say hey imagine
your worst nightmare
hey imagine the worst thing that could
happen to you besides [__] death
i'd be horrifying
speaking of bills you know what i saw on
tick tock this morning that a lot of
other people saw this guy proposed to
his wife his girlfriend in the stands
marty
yeah i have a tatted on my back now
real buffalonian [__]
so uh
off topics random little quick stories
let me get into this uh let me get into
my my notes real quick all right
we're bringing it back it's back
bringing another section of what's good
and then like a little overlay that's
good something cool
over the middle
what's good you guys ready
i looked up some stuff i found some
really cool articles that i've been
seeing lately
let's talk about this real quick i just
thought it was too cool not to bring up
are you ready this little boy's name is
davon johnson he's 11 years old have you
seen this
little boy he looks like a
tario with glasses remember tario a
little dancer kid he looks like that kid
like a little chunky kid with glasses
like just look fun all little fat kids
look fun like
they always look like you know what
you're maybe because i was a little fat
kid like you're nice i bet all jolly
that's how i think so like i was a nice
guy you're probably a nice kid um
you ready for what this little [__]
boy did this isn't what's good so
remember this is all cool [__]
oh boy's 11 years old in the sixth grade
school
he gave a heimlich maneuver to one of
his homies in schools classmates that
was choking to death
save the kid's life with the heimlich
maneuver right
i mean after that you're going home ah
so you know what i did today
[__] yeah asked the principal
mom like you put the dishes away you
know what i did today that's how i would
act like
you cleaned my room seriously i saved a
life anyway he saved a kid's life wow
great
walks home
as he's walking home remember this is
what's good sorry everybody just got
scared like oh god you guys no no it's a
good story
as a kid's walking home he walks by a
house that's on fire and saves an old
woman from the [__] house
this kid's [__] peter parker this kid
is spiderman
he saved a woman from a burning building
and see the classmate on the same day he
got an award from the city he's just
like with the mayor shaking his hand
this little mid this little superhero
what do you call him
what do you call what's his superhero
name like a little tiny fat kid
would you cut me a second i'll think of
something good
anyway the kid must have had the best
day of days uh when i did some [__] as a
kid yo i was thinking like you think the
news is gonna pick this up
he didn't use what you know he did i was
in the paper one time i think i talked
about this and they made me sound i
don't know if i talked about this they
made me sound real stupid
i'm good in school i'm good with that
[__]
i know harriet tubman is i know what the
[__] underground railroad is i know
who frederick douglass is
oh god i was outside of my school
with the [__] packers beanie long-ass
hair maybe that's why they did it to me
we interviewed four students about the
black history month blah blah blah blah
thomas zarajo grade nine and i'm like
you know what they put us my quote in
the newspaper with my face
oh oh hi
they asked about the [__]
underground railroad all these um like
it was like highlighting african
american heroes and they asked me for
frederick douglass and i went in on
frederick douglas because i just did a
report on this a [__]
told him everything about him everything
marty in a parking lot big jacket
and then she did this waiting for a
[__] to ask i was just playing
like i just did the [__] report [__]
oh you want to ask about frederick
douglass i got an a oh fred oh fred yeah
me and william go way back
in the newspaper i was all hyped it's
going to be the news people can't take a
picture like what me the new holy [__]
they pull oh come on man
are you ready i remember everything's
remember looking at the paper
at school and everybody like yo
you sound [__] oh man
i do sound stupid
thomas rowe my name my [__] last name
so everybody knows it's me thomas rowe
grade nine
frederick douglass comma he was
political that's it
he was political
[Laughter]
he was human he was he had hair
he was political
frederick douglass comma he was
political i was number two it's not like
they ran out of space uh-huh
that's what they exerted out
oh i didn't even say those words they're
not even a full sentence
they misquoted you it's a misquote bad
grammar not even a false bad journalism
that's all you gotta say
merced wrapped up right there boom
that's what you put in your paper i'd
even show my mom or my grandma was so
embarrassed i was like yo me the paper
it never came out
no they stopped the paper
i was thinking like they're not gonna
have enough room for all the [__] i was
all those facts i was spitting and [__]
just like the telemundo thing
oh they made me look like a piece i've
talked about it on here
it's just like the telemundo thing man i
still have people dm me all day yo i
just saw this thing with you on
telemundo
they made you sound bad but i know they
made me sound bad
i'm aware of it [__] what do you
think i didn't [__] post it in a lot
hype
anyway i forget what it was it was the
same shirt right there
i did a whole [__] 35 minute
interview with this lady on how kids
should not be [__] smoking cards
unregulated this unregulated that how
this law
and all they did was
oh voice over me and said
when i hit him real hard you know they
make me really cough i get hot
thomas were out with his view too he was
advocating people smoke marijuana and
smoke fate like
[__] it was the opposite did you filthy
it did me bad i even emailed the report
uh we talked about this anyway
dave dave arnold johnson
good [__] all right that's how we talked
about it
let's go let's see brent city over here
[__] yeah are you ready for this next
thing i saw i don't like
the
[__] bob dylan started playing i was
like yeah times are changing this is
[__] great this is sick
are you ready her name is i'm gonna
[__] butcher it
or any kaya para i'm gonna [__] that up
chick from new zealand
newscaster first [__] newscaster ever
with a [__] traditional tribal faced
hat
whole [__] tatted dude
she's the name is anchor in new zealand
like completely traditional [__] tats
nice covering all her [__] and she's
like in a suit
she's the news anchor that's like some
as dope as [__] national [__] though
this is like some gang related [__] no
no no that's she's from new zealand
that's like the traditional [__]
wow i couldn't believe i saw something
with a [__] face chat so that's still
take it seriously this is so cool i
would think it would be less it's not
like a face tattoo yeah it's not a face
tat
culture it's culture
just the fact that it's on tv like whoa
no way
that's cool
it was pretty [__] awesome so first
person ever
ever damn okay i'm never thinking about
it
reporter why would you have
not even a hand tattoo
so anyway shout out to her for [__]
crushing it that's so sick i bet she
wouldn't feel like this [__]
feeling so and then she stomped her feet
and did that whole thing
my homie does that he's in a group that
does the dances so i always see him like
yo why are you yelling at me
[__] stop
it's like some traditional dance [__]
they do
rosie's godson does it too
but
i always make fun of him just because
it's hard to do and scary like you guys
look
weak yeah right [__] they're all
sick sick and screaming
those chances are scary as [__]
that should be a war chant
it should be a regular dance that's like
[__] you do before you guys are gonna
find us all right hold on hold on
b2k
from the b2k like oh no
they got omarion on their team i ain't
[__] fighting these mothers oh i'm a
crime i'm a chrono marion on their team
damn chris brown just walked in like
[__]
anyway shout out to her for crushing it
that's so [__] tight
um
are you ready i have another uh piece of
what's good
oh you know what
hold on i got a question about that did
mike tyson get his face tap removed
or is it still there it's still there
it's still there okay that [__] i must
just be used to seeing it cuz i was just
i was thinking face tattoos and i'm like
i don't know i just don't like it i i
must not recognize it on him as much as
when he [__] first got it because
you're just scared of him you look at
him like you don't even look at the face
tattoos yeah exactly yeah
yeah don't [__] hit me shark eyes on
chad oh yeah he definitely got short
guys
he's the coolest [__] yeah
though
i see all the interviews with him he
seems like such i just want to smoke
jones and go i know right and i feel
like he would just be
as time goes on with the podcast it's
gonna happen one day the the top tier of
people that we want just becomes more
and more special like how amazing that
would [__] be i felt like mike tyson
would be such a fun [__] to talk
to not even about fighting just like hey
you've seen this movie yeah i've seen
that i think with you he would get he
would realize right away like this isn't
like my normal interview and like
get relaxed i never think about it like
that cause it's [__] me yeah
coming to talk to a gu because you gotta
remember i don't look at myself as in
i just i'm thomas how you doing
it's like yo you're gonna go meet this
dude that's been making content for a
long time what did you do oh he gets
[__] up like what kind of [__] up
you know people do hot ones yeah times
10 but with wheat
i don't want to go on i'm kind of scared
but no you don't have to smoke all right
is he nice no he's super nice oh like is
he going to be [__] fun no he's a fun
guy i was just like no it's fun because
it doesn't sound normal like no it's fun
no no no no no but can we talk about
anything though yeah yeah he smokes me
like yep
yeah it is definitely it doesn't even
sound real yeah it's hard to describe
because it sounds like what interview
you going to oh we're just getting
[__] up like what kind of interview is
that
you just
yeah
life drugs problems accomplishments
everything in between it's perfect but
yeah i think mike tyson coming on our
show would be like oh this kid
yeah i [__] with him yeah he'd think
it's something i'm like this is a small
[__] weed i got some questions
that's it i never think about it as as
me but if i was watching this from an
outside perspective like yo that show
looks like it's kind of fun to be on
yeah if you open up and you're down to
chill we have a jessamine paluso episode
okay exactly
i want to hear his rick james stories
can you imagine i got i got pictures of
them you know back in the day and [__]
on my computer like
those would be [__] insane
oh yeah never heard anything about that
they man he's got can you imagine being
mike tyson in the [__] eighties
walking around the most whatever that
mike tyson's
you're the champ
that's one that's one thing like the one
you are the you're the baddest man on
the planet on top of being one of the
most famous people on the planet well
then you have the other layers on the
planet then it's famous then it's the
most feared man not even athlete
feared man yeah i don't want to fight
him
nobody wants to [__] fight that man
like that's a thing to walk around that
must be a lot of burden
yeah it's a burden to hold that's a dude
that's already walking around with so
much burden it is man like people like
looking at you dirty that like i bet you
can walk his ass like you can't go to
the store without people dogging you or
like just swarming like yo jab oh [__]
it's not the same life anymore yeah did
we ever talk about on here like his
childhood at all
yeah [__] is crazy just [__] sad go
and watch his rogans because he talks
about how they hypnotized him
turned him into what he is man and just
even before he started training as a
fighter coming up in brooklyn and
not basically not having parents yeah
robin [__] up it was [__] up but i
like mike tyson now hell yeah he's so
introspective cool
i like i like seeing him check
[__] when they try to say
something she's like why the [__] you
talking like that but why
oh you better answer you better [__]
answer are you talking about the one
interview from back i don't even know
how far back in the day it was he's i've
seen him do check people multiple times
five people but the one time when he
really got [__] mad was like
somebody it was like a tv interview i
think i don't remember i've seen that
you know you're a [__] real piece of
[__] yeah because
on his show yeah yeah yeah where he's
checked people on his show gotcha on his
podcast that's all i'm talking about
gotcha uh all the other [__] was
previous mike tyson yeah that was before
mike tyson was him now now he's just
like
the older guy that just wants to smoke
[__] weed with you
and i love that so much yeah but he'll
also kill you yeah
in a heartbeat
great it's a great friend to have yeah
it's a cool friend like he got my back
right all right cool let's go smoke some
[__] weed and jump on the jungle gym
for a while i don't know i feel like he
would go to the lego land with me and
[__] yeah let's go legolas
or something did you imagine that vlog
yolo times mike tyson tripping balls on
[__] legoland tripping balls on
go-karts
man that sounds so fun
it's slow slow-mo last
a slow-mo mike tyson oh my god
he's in a ball pit it's like a suspect
in the movies
this is a movie where is it that mike
tyson please
you know it's okay
within a couple years we'll have our
movie
podcasters podcast this is fun
but we're going to make
it's coming levels to the show levels
it's coming guys
um
all right cool well you know that mike
tyson man how much you love
it's my mom's favorite person ever
mm-hmm
he's like
i mean yeah since i was a kid though
iconic
athlete interesting person like truly
persona take away the boxing and i still
want to talk to mike tyson
he's just so cool bro he's just such a
cool [__] i love that his
podcast is so big too [__] [__] blew up
like so fast it's too interesting yeah
i see the most scariest man's planet on
the planet's
perspective on things
yep something i watch
all right on to the next section of
what's good real quick
what's up guys welcome to the mid-roll
ad read this is one of our newest
sponsors this is fanduel this ad read is
for super bowl 56 yes as of today if you
have fanduel if you have the app if you
refer a friend when that friend spends
ten dollars any kind of ten dollar bet
you both get a 50 bonus
okay you both get 50 bonus and you're
both automatically entered in the
sweepstakes for the super bowl all
expenses paid trip to super bowl 56
everything all inclusive two tickets to
super bowl 56 right now fanduel
sportsbook that's the app you have to
have and if you already have it you're a
step ahead do you see what i'm saying
not only do you refer a friend you get
into the super bowl sweepstakes you
prefer a friend they make one bet you
both get 50 bucks and you both get a
chance to win this is a very easy app to
use when you win you get paid within two
hours there's no waiting there's no form
to fill out you have to wait and mail
something in it's easy it's for people
like me and you that like oh yeah this
this much on this team i get paid it's
very simple straightforward so if sports
betting is something you're allowed to
do in your state sports spending
something you're interested in download
fanduel and on top of everything guys
another little added thing right now use
code dope as usual it's a risk-free bet
up to a thousand dollars for everyone
out there that bets you know how
significant that is and it's all you
have to do is type our code in if you go
download the app it's helping us out
it's helping you out you might get to go
to the super bowl you guys know the
disclaimer about betting you got to be
21 it's got to be legal in your state so
right off the bat you make sure you're
good so right now go download fanduel go
see for yourself why it's america's
number one sports book rosie was telling
me the other day
i had no idea i'm like why would i i
don't [__] watch the news
you guys know i'm super for like
[__] just being okay with
themselves like type [__] you know like
oh you're gay you're saying gay fool
it's fine or your parents don't like it
you don't have to hang out with your
parents but i get it i get people's
dilemma like i'll lose my whole family
if i say this [__]
i've heard it all you understand i've
heard so many stories but my thing is
more of uh
when people just let people be
you know like we were talking about the
rupaul like i love that [__]
[__] are loving their life just
on the show and everybody that watches
them supports them
and everyone so it's like
[__] yeah
so i didn't know rosie goes to this
thing called drag brunch a lot my mom my
sister my aunts go a lot
it's a bunch of drag queens and it's a
brunch where you like you eat it's like
a big muffin but it's a show
it's like a show like
some are comedians some are dancers some
are lip-synchers some are impersonators
it's like a variety show
but it's bottomless mimosas and food and
[__] and everybody that's eating at the
table at this auditorium
like just throwing monies and tips like
it's [__] cool i haven't gone yet i
need to go i know i need to go i just
every time rosie goes i'm doing some
other [__]
it looks really [__] funny right it
looks like really cool
and rosie goes a lot so she knows a lot
of the performers right and a lot of the
performers uh smoke weed so they already
followed [__] rosie
it's a perfect community for us she
loves that [__] if you guys don't talk
about it's men dressed up as chicks that
pants better than chicks and heels it's
the craziest you've ever seen
anyway
the drag brunch thing rosie goes all the
time cool my mom my sister everybody
one of these
women
is a councilman in west hollywood got
elected the first trans person
to be elected
counts i can't remember the title she
has
but i just wanted to bring it up because
i thought it was really [__] cool i
thought it was really [__] cool
i was just talking to my grandma grace
about this
have you talked about west hollywood
before boys town
on my first trip to la story i think
okay i talked about it because i was
just telling my grandma like west
hollywood's like one of the coolest
places ever it's
gay people lesbian people
never once seen an argument or a fight
or a gang attack
or someone get jumped yeah it's the
street that looks like a third world
contractor everyone's there
to have fun
it's like an off-limits zone of
hatred i don't know what to say it's
very cool
i've gone there with my uncles and my
uncle's gay i've gone through my uncles
and his husband and [__]
it's wild as [__]
i'm just gonna say that
it's [__] insane i've only been there
that one time but it's like way cleaner
than the rest of la right there's no
trash out there yeah
it was wild though it was wild as [__]
anyway
uh
the reason i brought it up because one
of the performers is a councilwoman that
goes to the dragon brunch
no they know that she does the drag
shows
has a persona as a drag queen still
elected as a trans person which is
pretty [__] awesome i want to bring
it up i thought it was pretty [__]
cool we're talking about all these
people [__] doing dope [__]
i can't i wish i remembered her name i
shouldn't ask her before i started just
i just it's not even in my notes i just
brought it up
um i'll ask rosie but yeah i thought it
was really cool of west hollywood
[__] awesome
good [__]
that's awesome that's all it's gonna
bring up that's it that's it that's
what's good that's that's what's good
uh last i know it's a long section but
last section of what's good are you guys
ready
we don't have a button for that do you
have a
oh of course hold on let's see what we
got going here hold on what's good purge
don't no that's terrible that's that's
what's bad okay all right good point all
right that's scary uh
definitely not what's good
no no no no no just do explosion
you ready for this part
hold on we can excite let's just say we
can assign the explosion to what's good
now so
what's good you ready for my last
section
giveaway time we've never really done
that on this channel are you [__]
ready
marty and i decided since it's a lot the
first episode of the year it's new
year's eve to right now
and i think this comes out the third
it's the last episode of the our first
episode of the year
uh we want to start it off right we want
to start it off fun we're going to start
off with saying [__] thank you
before i start any of this
please don't feel left out
if your name wasn't called out of the
hundreds of thousands of people please
don't take it personal i've done
giveaways before and people you didn't
pick me i'm in every one of your videos
but bro i don't know that
i'm sorry also if i did pick you
somebody else would say what you just
said to me
i can never be like
please everybody can never it's never
going to happen
please don't take it personal like i
looked at your name like oh i see him
all the time [__] that guy that's not
what's happening we did it randomly all
right we picked out of a couple [__]
different names just picked a name so
you might have almost been a winner i
just picked the other name random sorry
won't be the last time it won't be the
last giveaway i just want to say that
before we start because people get very
upset also this is gonna be [__]
awesome i have to bring my phone out
here we go
kind of scared me
here we go here we go
so this is what we did
you guys ready
i decided to go
and pick a few things and me and marty
said we're going to do a giveaway the
winners of this is going to get one of
everything we have in merch okay you get
the puff print tee
you get the one of me and marty and then
you get the do you and the sticker pack
so you get four [__] items your size
all we need is you to email us just go
to the about section on our youtube
channel go to the about section it'll
have a contact email it's in there right
couldn't tell you on that and if it
isn't we'll add it okay so
on our email guys the winners all you
gotta do is send us a screenshot of your
account while being logged into your
account so we know it's you there's
gonna be a lot of people just picking
your account screenshotting like it's me
it's me
no we're gonna make sure it's you
just give us your size and address and
we're gonna ship it out to you thank you
for [__] supporting thank you for
everything this is not the last
giveaways we're gonna do so please don't
get upset if you don't win
let's get this started
so i went to the very first episode the
advent the origins of yola i went
through the comments and i just picked
somebody if you were in that first one
you have been here since the start so i
wanted to give everybody a special thank
you so much for being in that first
episode
first winner big mountains big space
mountains
oh i've seen his name a few times i have
a photographic memory i just remember
the
colors of the picture with the word
that's how i remember people's stuff big
space mountains big space mountain big
and then a space mountain
and then his profile has a little bit of
blue looks like a tree
a little bit of blue that's how i always
remember the name anyway i picked yours
his comment this is going to be epic now
that joe rogan left youtube you can take
over and become the biggest podcast on
youtube i believe in you man keep it up
big mountain said that 10 months ago
damn all right he said that 10 months
ago
[__] thank you bro you are our first
winner i didn't pick pick it because of
he said some cool [__] i picked it
because he said i was like [__] yeah
thank you for the comment two i know
you've been in the first one and i've
seen you multiple times and you just
happened to be in the first one i just
wanted to grab somebody from that first
episode so thank you so much big
mountains hit us up email us you're the
winner number one
and then i have this picture of michael
scott
marty just got me the light switch
light switch sorry that was in my photo
album
here we go
the next winner
the next winner is from the episode
tales from the hood with ochi i just
wanted to pick one of my favorite
episodes and that's one of my favorite
[__] episodes yeah oh before we
continue
a lot of people are thousands of people
like yo you got to stop talking over og
it's mad rude you guys are [__] up
i do that on purpose all right guys i
[__] talk over og all the time
because he's
og does michael scott [__] does it
called improv conversation he does this
to me every day he did it to me
yesterday as he starts talking he goes
you know
and i know og so well that i know he's
got nothing to say
i know when he does certain things i'm
like you're not going to say anything
you're just talking [__] to me he went
you know
and as he paused i went you got nothing
to say huh
shut up brody it's like you had nothing
to say you were just trying to get my
attention so you can
go or something stupid and i knew he
wasn't gonna say anything and i know his
little things that he says he just
smiles like [__] you bro you alright you
copy i wasn't gonna say [__] like you
just made up two words so you go
you know what i really don't like like
he was just gonna say nothing so that's
why
that's why that when i do that to og i
talk over like hurry up come on
[__]
it's like your brother are you gonna say
like you know your [__] holy [__]
that's why i talk over og like that
because i know he's like
because if i didn't he would just sit
there well
well you know what i mean bro
shut up let's talk that's why i [__]
with og so heavy before we start
just want to put that out there because
people get pissed at me like i'm being
rude
you were dragging him
you know him off camera he's way more
talkative than that so it's like oh come
on [__] stop
anyway
this is from
tales from the uh hood with og this name
is osvaldo ambriz this is from
there you go from six months ago
i picked you because your comment is
[__] hilarious
our fans are so [__] funny i know
dude there's some really good comments
in there sometimes
i picked you because it was so [__]
funny email us send us a screenshot of
you inside your account so we know it's
you says the screenshot you'll win
you're winner number two his qu his
comment says oh g talks like he's
hungover and is trying to remember what
happened the night before
that's exactly
exactly how og talks like damn whoa
no no what a wait what did i do
oh that's right that's right that's
right that's right i threw up like that
that is og that's a conversation with og
you have to tell him what no you did
this last night oh you're right i did do
that last night like i wasn't even there
yeah you were restarting every story
that's an observational ass car but so
funny bro so funny so i had to pick you
thank you so much
that's winner number two all right i
just picked it from that comment because
i don't know i just thought it was funny
it's one of my favorite episodes
are you ready
i picked another person
from the og episode because i just
thought this one wasn't funny was just a
good comment and it's one of my favorite
episodes remember that guys i go through
the comments i answer back [__] so
be in there you ready
this is from charles young same episode
six months ago
og is what happens when a young drug
dealer doesn't go to jail doesn't get
shot for gangbanging and doesn't get
caught in addiction to depression
that's a [__] good point he weaved
out of all those bad things man
and what happens you get og he's a
goddamn podcast star you get the you get
that guy
back with the pinky ring puffing [__]
watching the cameras and [__] yep just
chilling and running the [__]
dispenser
that's all he does
great comment microphone hey full
telephone get the [__] out of here
hey tell that carter park better
og's on that show like hey tell that
photo to be parker like that that's
[__] rude
yeah
so i thought that was great charles
young same thing screenshot us uh inside
your account email us you're the third
winner
ready on to my next two
my next two i wanted to say
thank you to
this is nothing to do with
race or sex or anything like that
but we see our our graphics and our
back end stuff we're about 90 percent
male it says in 10 women which is cool i
love that there's girls over here just
loving our [__] which is [__] awesome
and i don't want them to feel left out i
want you guys to know like yo we
appreciate you guys alright
so
i pick two girls
that i see non-stop all right let's go
all the time all the [__] time and i
know this person is a girl there's no
profile picture i wouldn't know because
i remember one comment saying that she
was a girl and if you're not a girl and
i [__] up you still win and i'm sorry
for misremembering but there's thousands
of [__] names
this is b gal four nine nine b g a l l
four nine nine with a purple
b
i see that name all the time always in
there you're always there
thank you so much and like i said before
there's gonna be people going i'm in
there dude what the [__]
we're not leaving down on purpose this
is this is the first first of many
giveaways please it's our first real
merch first drop so just let us pick
some people i'm promising we're not
leaving anybody out intentionally
be gal
you we talk in the chat all the [__]
time you're always there
thank you so much do the same thing hit
us up with your email uh inside your
chat and we'll send you everything
thank you for always being here up next
you already know i had to she's in here
all the [__] time elizabeth it just
says elizabeth and a picture of her
like this that's how i always remember
it's her it's just
elizabeth a hair and some girl like that
i always remember just like a person the
hair the word
the name elizabeth just once you're
lucky to just get that name you just got
the name on youtube nobody took it
in 2010 damn
anyway you're in there all the time i
see you every every drop thank you so
much elizabeth send us your account send
us your stuff and we'll send you out
you're winner number five i think that
was yeah and that's all the winners i
have on there except
i have one more in my head i see her all
the time
you know who you are though i can't
remember the profile picture
specifically but it has
like there was some yellow i
i can't remember but you know your name
and you know who i'm talking about
i know the name okay but the profile
picture it's sarah bynes sarah barnes
sarah b-y-r-n-s
or b-a-r-n sarah i see you all the time
you talk about your husband you both
watch the show that's all i remember
sarah
uh i'll screenshot it send it to you
i'll find your account that way we know
exactly what it is because i know
exactly i see her name and i know
exactly who it is
sarah thank you so much do us a favor
send us your size uh you're the last
winner you're not even on my sh i just i
know your name right off the top of my
head i know you're a chick
it's kind of just like you know what
this is the girl says the first three
winners of dudes we'll do the girls in
the second just make it fair also say
thank you for being here and talking
through our manscaped ads just sitting
here while we talk through dick jokes
and [__] appreciate it so yeah thank you
guys yes thank you so much sarah
elizabeth b gal charles young osvaldo
ambriz
big mountains let's all win thank you so
much you guys are all gonna get all the
merch we have
thank you [__] appreciate you guys
that is the end of what's good we just
wanted to start the year off with some
[__] giveaways say thank you so much
[__] appreciate you i know it's
another solo episode guys me and marty
were just talking about it it's very
hard to book people right now during
christmas and new year's and people just
growing up chronic virus is [__] [__]
up right now all right it's [__]
everybody up i've been doing that what's
up stay over there i'm not getting very
very very picky about the people that
we're gonna have on the show extremely
picky about our guests and it sounds
like we're dicks we're not dicks
we just
all right put it this way
you know there's certain people in your
neighborhood
i'd say this
you're in your neighborhood everybody's
hanging outside a liquor store or some
[__] right
nobody says what's up to this fool but
he's from the neighborhood and you're
the only one that goes oh what's up oh
yeah yeah yeah come come chill with me
come cheer me everybody look at you like
what the [__] you bringing this fool
over you know what he did
you just okayed that guy and now
everybody looks you guilty by
association
do you do does that make sense
like the dude that beat up his mom walks
by nobody [__] them no more because he
everybody heard he whipped his mom's ass
but you're like yo what's up charles
what's up man how you doing
like before you're okay with that fool
what the [__]
then now you're like look down a little
fun
i'm not doing that to myself
there's people out there that done some
stupid [__] [__] all right
we just don't want to associate
ourselves with everybody we can't i
wouldn't do it in real life i'm not
gonna do it on the [__] show
and beyond that that's how i feel yeah
of course i mean that's the first filter
that people kind of pass through but
then it's like we need we need guests
that the fans are gonna be excited for
yeah not just we
because there's people me and you are
excited for yeah totally fans are gonna
like yeah that's what i mean like yeah
the show needs just guess that the fans
are gonna really we want you guys to be
happy like stoked about the guests not
just me and marty filling the blank of a
gust yeah
that's cool if we were psyched but
we would like you guys to be happy to be
soaked it is our show but it's also your
guys's show too
you guys have said a lot of things and
we've changed it and done it yeah so i
think the point is we didn't just want
to rush out and just grab a random guess
just to fill the slot because we have
some serious [__] guests booked this
week so is tricky for people this
january month we have some very awesome
[__] guest coming
super super dope working real hard on
that this whole next first quarter is
going to be
a quarter three months the first three
months is dumb tight
it's planting seeds planting seeds son
sometimes you to plant some seeds and
[__] sprout up in the future when you
need them maybe i could have said
we're just looking for guests that we
want to talk to and you guys maybe i
should have left out the
guilty by associations no you can't be a
overt piece of [__] and come on the show
that is the first filter you gotta pass
through maybe i should have just said
that we just don't want people that are
bad people on the show they should have
said that to begin with yeah all right
cause that's true there's people that
podcast and [__] that i wouldn't have on
the show [__] no
never
there's some people i'm i was fans of
and i go oh no
we're not going to get into it because
it got his age restricted last time but
let's leave it at that it makes me sad
because i see certain people i'm like
laughing my ass off of [__] and to go
you got to be a creep
you're so [__] funny it hurts me to
go
no
yeah it's like
this weed's so fire who grew it yeah
throw it away but i have to
that's how i feel with certain comedians
or famous fools like
i can't [__] with you yeah even if even
if it's a situation where it's like damn
i know i can make it happen and it
probably has a ton of views and changes
views can't do it can't say [__] no loud
enough
yeah good way to put it kids they [__]
no loud enough
that's a shirt
that was i love that that was great
um
so marty let me get right into this what
are we at like 112
where the play is dwell oh [__]
are you ready
you guys ready
yo you don't be cool to interview 16
year old marty
that'd be crazy just bang him at the
table you over there like so
first off how did we do this
second what's your life like
that would be [__] awesome
yo could you imagine if you can actually
interview your younger self i'd sit here
go bro
i could smoke this to your face don't
worry i wasn't i was saying no [__]
heavy to weave being like a whole joy to
my face well let me think 16.
yeah just being like like that's what
i'm like those are yeah don't worry it's
gonna be all right
the whole time just just convincing my
younger self just do whatever you think
that's in your brain that you should do
go with it go go with it all right
she's gross
good job
all right i don't know some
final destination [__] [__] uh here
we go i would have sounded like a real
[__] idiot i think
i'm glad there's no footage i had no
cameras and [__] you know
i wish i had i'm pretty sure i would
have sounded like a pretty i've been i
don't know when you when you lose a
parent you think about your life a lot
and you think about you think about
being a kid it makes you feel like a kid
for some reason i've already gone
through this so it wasn't that
i've already gone through all this but
you you think about your childhood and
you think about yourself as a kid and
what you were like and all that the [__]
is weird it's interesting
very [__] interesting for sure
nothing changed for me mm-hmm
yeah in some ways yeah like i've i feel
like
some ways i'm like the exact same
but in some ways i was just so ignorant
oh for sure young ignorance is real yeah
young ignorance is mad real
i'm glad i'm i'm doing what i'm doing at
this age and not when i was at that age
i would have [__] it off yeah yeah big
time
but here we are you guys ready marty
last episode we were talking something
super cool like yo we should get like
somebody to do story time like a sick
intro so every time we talk about story
time we can press play and like it would
start
we did talk about that did you talk
about that
didn't we we did just excite the
explosion to what's good didn't we what
did we do for story time marty what did
you do this week
hailing from merced california
you know him by the name dope as yola
let's get this adventure started
it's time
for
story
time
[Applause]
[Music]
yo his [__] bruce buffer guys
that's bruce buffer
in case you [__] forgot
that [__] is legally used for commercial
purposes
now for us he did it for our show
marty pulled this [__] off
so sorry can we do one time i know it
might be annoying for some of you guys
but can we do what we're doing for the
true fans out there
hailing from merced california
you know him by the name dope as yola
let's get this adventure started
it's time for
story
time
this [__] is so sick
oh my god
it's so much [__] better the second
time
special episode guys i already got that
done in one week
we dropped that video monday marty got
that [__] done in five days
i don't know how the [__] happened
i've already got it done
shit's crazy holy [__] we don't know
bruce either no we don't
marty just [__] got it done all right
yeah he's like yeah you can use it for
your show no
did we pitch something to come on the
podcast afterwards may or may not have
if you guys want bruce on the podcast if
you want to let him know he's been a
[__] amazing guest refer to joey diaz
dude
that's a way for right now that's one
thing you guys could do
to help the show
if you want a certain guest
go on their instagram and blow them the
[__] up tag them like yo go on the
dope's usual podcast tag our instagram
like dj ghost the other day you can
[__] [__] six thousand thousand
people tagging jesus christ so i we
appreciate that thank you [__]
awesome so we appreciate you guys so
thank you so much but yeah bruce buffer
shout out to you man
we were just hyping this [__] up
last month let's be wrong i've never
heard that on a podcast before
i didn't i could be wrong
i've never heard that on a [__]
podcast before but bruce is a goddamn
legend if you don't know now you don't
look him up god damn it
that's the ufc announcer when he brings
everybody out the guy with the
microphone that's bruce buffer he did it
like a fighter too i love that
university of california
i knew we couldn't push him too far
he did more than i asked for i thought
all i wanted was the it's time story
time and it's time oh that was so hard
it's weird hearing it without the crowd
noise yeah yeah yeah hold on hold on
hold on sorry
hailing from merced california all right
all right know him by the name dope as
yola
let's get this adventure started you can
stop you can stop it if not i'm gonna
get like i don't flip this [__] table
no more i want to hear your story that's
the new intro though from time to time
yeah sometimes guys when we introduce
stories and story time on the show with
marty's overlays we might chop that up a
little bit and throw it into something
so it's gonna be bruce buffer announcing
our story times from now that shouldn't
do a [__] song have bruce out here
it's just [__] swiss beasts get out
of here
oh so sorry that's our introduction to
story time let's hop right into it we're
at what one what
112.
i have four stories
damn we're not long all right
so four stories but we have to have a we
have to have this episode done in two
days
edited fully so
we're pressed for time
i don't know we're always seeing like
that lately it's just because the guests
this month has had us out there's been
[__] unfucking
off i started a new company doing a
bunch of [__]
so let's let's get started ready story
time
you guys ever see my snapchat all right
my snapchat i'm not gonna say the name
on here
because there's other ones that have the
same name that are fake and scam people
so what you do is you go to my instagram
go to my instagram click the link in my
bio it's gonna have every social media i
have
click the snapchat one that's my real
snapchat if you want to go to my youtube
dobesiola channel go to about section
and my snapchat is linked right there my
real one
i can say the name like i said because
people just copy the name
uh snapchat's just stopped that
it's not how are you saying yes stupid
because there's two names there's a
username and a name so one that shows
big people just see the name and forget
like oh wait that's not the username
and they buy packs from this guy he
never sends them the week and they think
it's me so it's not me all right i'm
never gonna openly advertise [__]
illegal weasels
so my snapchat i do something called
stash and dash shout out to my homie uh
we should smoke he started doing this
thing called stash nest where he just
leave some weeds somewhere and somebody
pick it up like yo if you're in this
area pick it up free weed
oh you know what i want to do that and i
started doing it and i just ran with it
for forever but shout out to him he's
the first person i ever saw do that and
i thought it was a really cool idea i'm
not just stealing a [__] i'm saying it
was his idea
but i've done it for like the past six
years i've never stopped i just kept it
going so what i do say i have like
an eighth say i have an ounce and i want
to give it to somebody what i'll do is
i'll go on my snapchat
record where i am no matter what state
i've done in other states i've done in
other cities it's just no matter where
i'm at
but yo i'm at the corner of this and
this i got this [__] ounce if you're
in this area come get it first person
here gets to have it it's gonna be right
under this bush behind this wall
and then i leave
and i know a lot of you what if a kid
finds it you think the kid within five
minutes is gonna be crawling under a
bush
downtown l.a
if that's true
get mad at his parents not me
anyway people you people what if a kid
finds it what if a kid finds it
good lucky kid i wish i found that as a
kid but no don't worry most of the time
i just waiting across the street until
somebody sees it i drive off
the second i see someone pull up i drive
off
that's it i don't want somebody like
going there just to rob me and like oh
there he is let's rock that's why i
leave all right it's not because i don't
want to hang out it's because people are
[__] creeps anyway um
i gotta run on my joint that's the first
run i've had in like [__] 10 years
wow
i've had a runny joint a long time what
the [__] man that was my wow first
career was runny joints
so uh
anyway stash and dash i've been doing it
for a long long long time
sometimes i'll tell everybody hey i'll
be in
echo park in an hour i'll do a stash and
dash
and some people will drop everything
they do and just show up at the places
that's why i don't stash i don't say
where i'm going to be first
because the stashes are gone in less
than five minutes there's always
somebody in an area around the state
whether i'm [__] fresno or merced
somebody's always there in five minutes
we have a big following man that's crazy
it's cr it's insane and sometimes the
merced i would see like five people hit
the same time and fight over [__] so
that's why i started doing multiple
things so people don't get like fight
over i've seen people [__] almost
fight one time at the old hometown of
famer said everybody met up and like
we're hugging over it i'm like oh bro
stop please
anyway
one time i did an echo park just tell
everybody where i was gonna be
but i didn't say win i said i'll be at
echo park today and i'm just stashing
dash that way there's not people sitting
there just waiting for me you know
i say i'm gonna drop a stash nasty
couple eighths i get by a tree right by
a tree i'm like yo
i'm about to post i posted it already
i'll be in echo park in like two hours
just said that i didn't say where part
of echo park
i am about
to put the wheat down i'm recording hey
i'm gonna be right here and i notice
there's a guy right about 15 feet from
me
don't sneak up on me i i already i see
everything
i see you even though i don't look i see
you i already see you and i'm waiting
for you to walk up on me in case i'm
weird
i already knew he was there is what i'm
trying to say and i'm doing it and i put
it down as i'm putting it down i look
him what's up man he goes
here's a stash and dash
and i go oh i thought you were trying to
be a creep full you're here for the
stash dash already
and he goes yeah you know i lived down
the street you said you'd be here in a
couple hours so like
well i didn't even put it down bro it's
your i'm not gonna even post this then
but here
you know who that guy was
kenny causes
you know causes does makes beats you
know what b he made our intro hmm that's
how we got our intro oh [__] i didn't
know you met this dude that's how i got
the intro
so i met him at a stash and she goes yo
well big fam like thanks boys yeah i
make music if you ever want to get some
beats for your instagram youtube it's
2018 19.
like that's cool man
i just changed emails and one day sent
me some musical these are kind of tight
[__] yeah and one time going through
them and i heard our intro
what is this
and i automatically email i emailed him
back like yo did you make this he goes
yeah
can i can i use this for a song for an
intro he goes dude use anything so
that's why he's he's linked in every one
of my youtube videos yeah i've always
loved that you've always done that yeah
i link his spotify on every youtube
video people always say what's the intro
song see my video right in the bottom of
my links
um
that's how we get the intro song
about that yeah from him it's on spotify
yeah and it's called the yolo's intro
check it out bro it's or it's called
perfect
p-u-r-r-f-f-f-e-c-t or some [__] perfect
but yeah
kenny causes shout out to kenny i don't
know what happened but he hasn't hit me
back in a long time i hope he's all good
hope he's okay but he hasn't answered my
text in a long time um
but yeah
that's how we got our intro man from
doing his dash damn i did not know that
all 2019 all music i heard all music in
any video was from him
all of it
sorry i didn't eat or drink water today
i just started feeling
sorry
i tried to get
past it
i tried a new brand of
vegan nuggets last night and then fell
asleep right after i didn't i was dumb i
woke up feeling sick
so here we are
sorry next one ready go
on to another the reason i'm doing these
stories in this story time is because
it's the giveaway we did the giveaways
in this one i thought you know what do
you have any stories about doing stash
dashes or giveaways or anything let's do
it ready go next story i'm in los banos
california if you're from los banos
shout out to you something in the
bathroom
i didn't know that until i was like 16.
yes yes it does a little lb los banos
like the toilet
nobody ever taught me man nobody just
left me out when it came to spanish oh
[__]
i lost bananas like there's a bathroom
like oh that sucks that place does suck
it's one road
it's one road where you get in trouble
for trafficking weed the [__] speed
limit drops dramatically in this in the
city
the story time uh uh uh
dear close calls i think part three
where i talked about me and my hobie
germ we got caught we got pulled over to
like a five or ten pack and he was
getting wet and reckless and he was like
yo by the way i got pulled over
leaving los banos toward merced you know
that one last rallies and you come to
the next light and that next light goes
from 35 or it goes from 55 to 35 out of
nowhere
that's why we got pulled over because
that little gap it's just a little speed
trap
that's
slos banos
it's just one speed trap it goes
straight straight through the town it's
got a [__] walmart and a rallies
that's lost battles that's at least what
i know i've never chilled there but i'm
not talking [__] lost man i was just
[__] the valley i [__] with the
valley uh anyway when i'm from merced
right there los banos
i was going to santa cruz so during las
vegas they told rosie let's do a stash
dash [__] it so i'm in a parking lot of
the walmart or target or whatever they
have there
i'm in the parking lot
los banos is not a big population marty
so i didn't expect people to be there
that fast i was like thinking 10 15. you
know one time it took me like 30 minutes
i was like bro no one lives in fresno
right now and i looked at my [__] and
never [__] processed it was still
processing
i've been staying for 30 minutes waiting
feeling like an [__] anyway
i stashed a bunch of [__] at this bush
and i go come get it and i went across
the parking lot and parked and just
waited
you know just to make sure no bumps walk
by and take all the weed or some [__]
and then like seven minutes later i just
see this dude sprinting
from way across in the summer way across
the parking lot to see this guy running
and i go rosie where the rosie it's got
to be him it's got to be somebody for
this to i'm like looking at him looking
at him
i see him start looking at pushing oh
that's him that's got to be he's got to
be somebody waiting for a stash dash
and i start driving over there i was
just going to just pop up like yo thanks
bro and then leave you know just to say
thank you because i was on my way out
anyway and i had to go that way
usually i just drive off you know i mean
so i pull up
and as i pull up
he finds it and he's off oh [__] yeah
and he's just like so stoked i pull up
and he's like what the [__] sick and
then like three other people pull up i
felt hella stupid because i was still
there and they don't get nothing
so i started like giving them [__] out
of my trunk i had you know i knew i had
some weed or something
and the kids talking to this one that
won and i'm talking to him like bro
you ran here he goes yeah dude
i [__] sprinted here i was taking a
[__]
i just
sprung up and started running oh that's
dedication god damn bro he's like i
wiped my ass and left i still got to go
to the bathroom
tmi but god damn no this beauty's like
bro i just like
got up and just started sprinting i
don't have a car
we were [__] for him he did a seven
minute mile he lived over a mile away he
got there like less than ten seven eight
eight minutes let's see i looked at him
and go
how far do you live man
i'm like you gotta get in the car i
can't let you walk back to your house i
know i feel like a pc [__] like i gotta
i'll take you home bro
and he just throw him home dude i feel
so bad he's sitting there pouring sweat
it's the middle of the summer he
sprinted having to take a [__]
shout out to you man those are the
people you want when in your stash yes
if i have a video or the picture i know
i took a picture of him like in the car
like i got i got to take a picture the
one time i took a fan look
he sprinted and i dropped him off and
his [__] door was still damn sprinted
off he just gone bro
it was so tight it was so tight
anyway he won
i dropped him as [__]
dropped him off i left to santa cruz i
thought it was really cool i'm picturing
right now me hot sauce
i left my [__] headband at the
[__]
behind delaware park i'd
get out of here
oh if he dropped his way yeah
my idol when i was 16 stashing something
let's go
um
but i thought it was really funny i
remember that i will never forget that
they were looking at him like
no get in the car
get in the car because i had my money
like get in the car bro don't [__] my
money up but get in yeah
oh i didn't even think about that
honestly until afterwards
he wiped his ass first because i didn't
you know i mean i was just i can't let
you walk home man i feel like a piece of
[__] it's hot
okay that's story number two
these are quick these are like faster
stories so i'm not going to get crazy
long into them but i do want to tell
them
and we're thinking about giveaways and
stuff
so i thought
one of the times i've done we've talked
about multiple things on here but i
remember
i was in the sixth grade and i have you
know your friends you know i'm poor but
my grandma always made sure that we
didn't feel hella poor because my
grandma always had you on my grandpa
they like took care of my grandma
delores my grandpa uh grandpa tom
so remember when razer scooters came out
oh those were the biggest thing ever
remember that
so i remember thinking uh my grandma
asked me what i want for christmas
i would get it i want a razor scooter
you know be like i need that [__]
and i got one and i'm my homie from the
sixth grade my homie
lived with me and i knew he was
way more poor than i was you know
you know when you drive your homies off
from school one time you're like oh [__]
this is your house
like damn i thought i was all poor too
sure [__]
you still haven't watched malcolm in the
middle shame on you
but malcolm in the middle style house
but like not a nice one
unkept scr type [__]
and i knew his mom wasn't the greatest
but i was like uh okay
i feel bad for you bro but you're my
friend i remember i got money for
christmas or whatever anyway i wouldn't
bought him a [__] scooter
because i felt terrible because i knew
he was not gonna get that [__] i already
knew and we all were gonna get one like
me and my two other friends and i just
felt like [__] bro we gotta get him a
scooter
but i couldn't afford a razor scooter i
was a [__] kid i got like 50 bucks
for christmas so i bought him like a 60
[__]
one from the flea market you know but it
had like the same everything was exactly
the same
it was dead all the same it was a brazer
yeah it was like a braze
yeah it was not a phrase it has
something else
and i gave it to him i remember i gave
it to him
and then that's what i was like
[__] you didn't even give a [__] um
he was like it's not a razor
i heard the second head
he didn't tell it to me he told my other
friends huh
jonah just bought blitz
[__] you
[__] you man
i don't know why that story just played
so short but it popped in my head
i was so excited like yo he's gonna be
so hyped
oh
[__] you bro
sorry it's not the brand you wanted you
bougie [__]
we're
bored [__] you
another quick story about that same guy
life-changing uh
wonder years moment for me
uh my friend nick the one that passed
away i told you it's a guy named chris
we were talking in class and they're
like you smoke weed like yeah
you know that when you find out your
classmates supposed to be like do you
want to smoke weed together
you should get high
so he goes yeah you smoke weed
but everybody thought i was such a
square you know because i had those long
hair very smiling nobody like knew that
i was like you can't hi were you the 4.0
kid but
so
so i go to their house and the guy chris
happens to live with my friend with a ha
that i gave the scooter to in sixth
grade but this is now ninth grade i
still chill with my friend with a
scooter every day we play basketball
every [__] day he's got a hoop i walk
him home and i walk to my house after
and we play basketball for like an hour
just what we do you know he plays
basketball he's real white kid real
[__] good at basketball
and
his cousin is the kid chris
and chris is friends with nick it's the
first time i've ever met nick turned out
want to be one of my best friends but
that was like the first time i ever
talked to him
and i'm like
oh your cousin's who
that's like one of my best [__]
friends i don't want to say his name
because i won't make him feel bad in
case he's like you heard about that says
great [__]
yeah i don't want to make him feel bad
but yeah i heard about the scooty [__]
it's rosie's friend too real good friend
oh he's gonna know
i know i know all right
anyway [__] i feel bad now
anyway
i go like you're you're cousins with
chris and like chris this is one of my
best homies but you know every time i go
to our friend's house it's to play
basketball
not to hang out with his cousin that
just happens to live there he moved in
with him because his mom was doing bad
or some [__] she moved with the aunt
which is you know my friend's cousin and
nick nick and chris were friends and we
go to the house chris just went there i
didn't walk home with my friend
like i usually do
but i walked over there and he's like
what's up fool let's play basketball
and then back in man i'm like
i was gonna go get high with your cousin
and this new guy man that's cool
my friend super square at the time did
not smoke we thought it was the devil
[Music]
in the back of my hand i went ah yeah
uh
and then chris comes out because he's
just getting this little pipe
and like my friend looks down like
oh you're hanging out
yeah i mean because i didn't walk home
to school with him so he's like what
what's happening
my delinquent cousin's hanging out with
my best friend now
but i remember he had the ball and i'm
like oh no i was gonna go to the park
with them right now like he's like
we're gonna smoke
he's like oh
you know basketball
tomorrow i'm down but i was gonna go
smoke with him real quick
and everybody turned around i'll be back
and i turned around and as i was walking
and i looked back and he had the ball
and he bounced it once
and he was like you're not gonna play
basketball
and he just shot the ball
and i looked down and went
is this a damn my life is different
and i went and smoked wee with nick and
chris and never played basketball again
with him dude ever once
never again did we play basketball ever
and i always felt bad about it but i
think he felt played like you're gonna
do drugs now he's gonna do drugs all the
time now like i don't want to hang out
with you
and then he started [__] smoking weed
11th grade
yeah or no 12th grade started smoking
weed and drinking and [__] [__]
you know talking about [__] you man
we were best friends we were best
friends i felt so bad i remember he just
bounced it you know what
one single dribble it was one gym
i'll be back though
i remember it dude that's hard i
remember that day i went
i didn't i would have just walked to the
park and not told you i was with you
guys yeah i just want to smoke it's not
like i had an obligation to play
basketball with it yeah that's just our
thing mm-hmm no i i'm [__] good at
you know yeah i felt super bad i
remember i remember looking at him like
i'll be back uh-huh
never once ever again tacos
that reflect take you off the [__]
court that's tough that reefer will take
you off the court marty's a
seven-year-old black man
with the gator hand off [__] uh
chubs yeah he took his hand
they said i was going to be the next
arnold palmer
that wouldn't happen
i wouldn't play on the pro tour no more
ah that's cause you're black
hell no
damn alligator took my hand off
so we'll stop we're gonna get all the
way
into the first tournament
we're gonna stop talking
all right so those are my stories those
are my giveaway slash stash stories just
to make it relevant from the giveaways
today we didn't really have a theme we
didn't want to go in like
everything today is about mushrooms even
in the mushroom episode we talked about
a bunch of [__] first
our formulas change all the time i don't
know we're still working it out but uh
this is the last story and this last
story marty take it away
you started telling me the story last
night i faced i went stop stop
you gotta tell me
it's hilarious to me and i didn't want
to know the end
so
take it away well it's a little
anticlimactic i guess i don't know i
haven't really thought this one all the
way out but it was because we were
talking it was because yeah all right
so this as as all all stories this one
actually starts with goofy again
it does i mean it kind of takes place in
that era where
goofy had moved really briefly to
lackawanna right across the street
so much it was just
these my new little moments the more the
[__] podcast goes on the more i
realize what a [__] impact was like
on the april introduced me to april
all right he co-signed myspace yeah
so
i linked him with my okay my other boy
that we've talked about a couple times
the [__] with the um
where we had the incident with the
rental being crashed scary guy he's yeah
i mean um get it paid for i don't give a
[__] you guys got a boy
yeah yeah but he is one of my all-time
best friends though
so uh he was hustling and [__] and um i
had linked him with my boys in
lackawanna and we had these [__]
little butterfly tops going it was cool
we had put some actual quality in the
[__] hood
these little jars that we had what does
that mean so we had these little ten ten
sack jars and [__] so i had plugs yeah
yeah i didn't know what butterfly tops
meant sorry yeah i had i had linked them
so we had put some good weed in the
[__] hood in lackawanna and it was
going nicely so i linked my boy from
buffalo now he's coming to lachlan on
his own time
we're all doing music together we're
making a we're making a pretty big
connection where we're becoming one team
yeah
so i linked
uh i linked goofy
and this is when he walked goofy for the
weed i guess this is all in that time
frame i got they i had linked them all
up we were all kind of becoming one big
team we're all kind of getting to know
each other and [__]
and it was also around the time that we
watched the secret
and when we watched the secret and got
put onto that like it completely gave us
like the most [__] just confidence
you could imagine because now we're out
here like we can we can make [__] happen
like a good [__] like our mind stains
changed yeah good [__] is coming our way
like we and we're had all this potential
with our music and [__] we're like it
just changed the way that we thought so
we were expecting amazing [__] to happen
this was right after we watched the
secret and we were all [__] fired up
because we were we went from being like
hopeless on a lot of levels just broke
and like nothing's ever going to happen
at a core level to being like
we can make anything [__] happen
you know it really had that switch going
so anyway my boy that um that we were
talking about who i had plugged and we
had to you know we were just we had a
lot going on
uh
he was a little bit older than me he's
actually a lot older than me but he
called me and he's like i just won the
[__] lottery
and he was who said this my my boy that
uh that i was just referring to that
like um the first the the first one yeah
yeah yeah so you know me and him are we
we don't really talk anymore but we're
still one of my all-time best friends
so this was just a crazy weird situation
so he's like
29 [__] mill like i'm driving oh if
i'm driving over the bridge in lack one
okay so lock one is one of these towns
where it's divided by a [__] bridge
you got the [__] ghetto on one side
of the bridge and the less ghetto side
on the other side of the bridge
but you know
i'm driving over the bridge as he's
telling me this
like and he's [__] freaking out
now normally even back then i would
never speak on anything before it
happened just because i knew that for
music even like at that point this is in
my early 20s to not speak on things
before that they happened
but this [__] was so crazy and he was so
[__] amped up and we were so fired up
off the [__] secret
that when i got there i told my boy
now i i go over the bridge and now we're
in the [__] project now you're like
whoa what the [__] we just won the
lottery yeah so now we're we're in in
lac one in the baker homes where we
always used to hang out and i tell my
boy and he goes out and [__] fun
front and starts [__] freaking out 29
strong [__]
throwing this [__] [__] freaking out
now the whole hood starts buzzing
because you know everybody's right there
so before you know it everybody knows
this in [__] minutes
and i'm like god damn this [__] [__]
works i'm like
you know we're not talking [__] but
we're [__] freaking out because we're
thinking about everything that's about
to happen now and i'm thinking i i'm
like what ben's am i gonna go get
tomorrow i'm gonna quit my [__] job
tomorrow i'm this is right when i just
met april like we like won the [__]
lottery like
it was real we were [__] freaking out
the next day oh okay so that goes on all
night and there was one point
like early on right after it had just
happened we're [__] freaking out in
the front and one of my boys rolled down
the street and he was in the passenger
seat and i didn't know the dude driving
and like he stopped and i told him what
was going on and the dude driving's like
and somebody should beat you up
and i was like what that completely
struck me i was like what beat me up
what the [__] are you talking about
he's like out here thinking all like
basically like with this [__]
and i was like okay like the [__] ever
come to find you know the next morning i
wake up
i base i'm ready to quit my job now mind
you me and this dude worked in the same
building that's how we met
i would spend i don't know how this i
don't know how they let this slide i
would spend hours of my work day just
[__] standing in the halls of the
basement just chilling talking [__] with
him
every day in the bathroom and we would
just stand and just talk he was the
janitor of the building
that's how we it was crazy like i
pitched my mixtape to him in the [__]
basement
i heard him wrapping his ass off down
the halls i think we talked about this i
hit him with my mixtape we were best
friends ever since
but
i was calling him that morning i'm like
bro he knows my boss i'm like i'm
getting ready to quit and then like
you know no answer no answer later that
afternoon come to find out like ah bro i
wasn't misunderstanding that because he
didn't even really have like an answer
of what happened or how like i don't
even know where this i don't know if he
was just tripping i don't know if he was
confused i don't know if he was trying
to speak the [__] into existence
extremely aggressively
but the [__] wasn't he didn't win the
lottery the team didn't win the lottery
and then that kind of just put me back
in the position of being back in the
[__] hood with everybody going
where's the goddamn lottery money
it was he's my boy i've completely
brought him into the whole situation
over there you know because it's [__]
10 minutes apart i might as well be
worlds apart
you know but uh
yeah that's what i mean by that [__] was
kind of anti-climactic because
how long did it take you to go back
outside
i was back out there oh
it would have been like yeah i'm gonna
take the day off yeah bugging me today
yeah it was like it just it hurt my soul
to like break that to my boys and my
team and [__] it was such a win for the
team
we were such a [__] team
that sucks yeah
that that really sucked that yeah but
somehow yesterday when we were talking
about themes this story made sense
something we were talking about jog my
memory of this government was about to
give you money yeah that's the story
that sucks bro
if the guy that said somebody should
beat you up is that's so odd yeah those
are the people that never win in life
though i guess you see something that
something's too good to be true
who cares yeah you automatically look
for the bad yeah don't hang out but
that's that's the standard that's
baseline of everybody i was in the
position of looking for something
amazing to happen so when it did i was
like extra like oh [__] i've been i just
changed the way i think about the world
and now like
i mean it doesn't happen that quick it
doesn't and you know in my experience in
life it doesn't work like that but we
didn't know that yet i was ignorant to
this [__] still
but you know you live and you learn
point is don't speak on [__] till it's
in your hand yeah
truly truly and the reason marty brought
the story up yesterday is because i told
him i was super bummed
but not super bummed just two weeks
bummed
i i i would do this this deal
and i forgot like wait
we still got to pay back the initial
investment and i forgot about the
initial investment so i was telling my
like yo i'm so excited i get this
[__] check tomorrow
and it's not tomorrow it's in two and a
half weeks
so i was like yo i'm getting so much
[__] money soon
and then i went
[Music]
that sick feeling yeah i'm a throw up
okay so it's five times less than i
thought okay that's fine
oh it's a two weeks i thought it was
tomorrow
yeah but the only good thing about that
now is now it's like so everything here
is in profit
let me go as hard as i possibly can in
the next two weeks and just see what i
could possibly do
that now it's like okay
nothing's changed i just
if i would have put the number in my
head first i would have been like let's
get here and then it's profit
now oh my god what are we pro oh [__]
it's not profit yet so i was like oh
sick that's with every business i know
with the podcast but i forgot i thought
we were paying off what we did yeah no
we had to pay out the whole thing at
once not just piece by piece i was
thinking piece by piece that's not the
way it is me and my other partner were
like
oh yeah i guess we're both dumb we're
like yeah
we both jumped the gun in our brains
that's all that's all we just jumped the
gun we're still gonna get that still the
same amounts coming it's just gonna be
two weeks instead of
never like my situation
oh the lottery yeah never
um
yeah so that was that was the episode
man i think that was good i think that
was good i
i appreciate
appreciate you guys in the giveaways
thank you so much we just wanted like i
said there's six winners right
we'll get all your information
um i'll give you the last person's
youtube channel too yeah the more the
more cha opportunities we have to give
back we will but being
the more things we add on to the show
just like the merch line like with the
live shows whatever it's going to be
that's our priority yep
but guys yeah we just uh
we only have a day a day and a half to
edit maybe
so i got a
or may not be tripping balls later today
we'll see oh that's right you're gonna
be trying some mushrooms later on today
maybe i don't know don't forget to get
the caps yeah
um
yeah we got the bills marty cobells
bills on sunday we got atlanta tomorrow
tomorrow's saturday oh [__] playoff
start wild card [__]
right
don't let me act like i know what
[__] day it is bill's he's wearing a
bill swear don't wait let me act like i
don't know friday yeah
okay
so yeah yeah yeah i'm pretty high i'm
about to go to big bear right after this
literally pack up and drive to big bear
so that's gonna be kind of cool i've
been thinking it was saturday this whole
[__] day like my all my days are off
so
so yes guys thank you so much for being
here we did the what's good we talked
about you know what
i saw a comment saying hey you should do
an episode with marty with no notes i
kind of felt like
this is the styles of no notes that we
do because if it's no no it's just gonna
be rant city and i don't know if you
guys want that yeah i don't know if you
want that i for losing track of time
yeah easy real easy yeah we just sit
down and press go with no notes we don't
know what the [__] is gonna happen maybe
six hours
there's no i can't tell what time it is
there's no light coming it's the same
it's alaska out here man
i don't know what's happening
um but yeah thank you guys for being
here this is the first episode the very
first episode of the new year of a big
[__] year big year big year
coming
miller lie to ad reads uh start this
month
next up all right miller light starts
this month
guys thank you so much for being here we
have a lot of big guests coming in
january we have a lot of guests coming
in february everything is
new year all right me and marty are on
it we're going to be doing some more
[__] hopefully hiring some more people
for the team this year just so we can be
more efficient
we're looking at some more stuff all
right push trees i got a lot of new [__]
coming out
uh my
i'm just gonna pay i'm gonna buy the
bullets real quick uh my shipping is
times five what it normally is to get
here for my new bulk order
why it's supposed to be 900 shipping
it's 4 500 jesus christ because of the
chinese new year
oh and coronavirus things going on right
now with the ports uh
i'm gonna have to bite the bullet it's
for my new trays i'm gonna push trees
but i want the trays right now
so i'm just going to have to buy i'm
going to pay 4500 man you got to
sacrifice [__] how many trays is that
a lot
lose five bands of profit right off the
bat
but it's okay i want the trays you guys
want the trays they're coming out the
dopest i'm just going to say it now
shatter
batter
diamonds
oh [__] live resin i can't [__] wait
bro it looks better than most people's
regular [__]
it's shocking and it's with hash house
you know so it's like he's creating the
line of the look so i mean john's great
at that yeah i mean that's what he does
like the top of the line yeah that's
what he does so it's like hhc dabs to
your door
damn bro it looks it smells fire dab's
fine i gotta wrap my mind around the
process of that like it's crazy so we
have that coming out
yeah all right this is for the dope is
the dopest.com pushtrees.com
dopeasusualpodcast.com dopaziola app
we've already been mad busy but we have
a lot of changes coming to the app
that's why i haven't been going too hard
on the app because we're waiting for all
the changes to come the name change is
coming too and not to mention people
really take off [__] two weeks for
christmas
right they re that was [__] like we've
been sitting around waiting waiting for
people like oh we're out
automatic emails back yeah we're out of
the office until you're like oh man
[__] you know what i've been through
this past two weeks and we are grinding
right now i need you to be at work today
i need the service i pay for monthly to
work now
yes guys if everybody was like us your
[__] shipments would be in your hands
now for whatever you ordered from any
company
like people take two weeks off i i
emailed a certain company i will say who
i email a certain company i work with
just like yo i need the update blah blah
automatic email we'll be out of the
office until january
what
i need to it's gonna take a week after
yeah i'm like that instant gratification
kind of person brain like no get it done
now yeah let's film companies don't move
like that
i hate it
i hate it i know so uh
not you guys but i hate i hate that um
thank you guys so much for being here
first episode of the year i'm
from now on i'm gonna end these a lot
cleaner
i will never
i'm working on it you guys remember i
only been doing this for a few months
i'm working on it okay
shout out to [__] bruce buffer
bruce
buffer that [__] was so [__] cool
guys thank you so much for everything
thank you for being here thank you for
our new sponsor uh fanduel shout out to
you and uh yeah thank you guys so much
for being here thank you for for hanging
out with us please do us a favor leave a
like on the video it really [__]
helps just leave a like
it costs nothing just press that thumbs
up we appreciate it helps us so much it
helps our video circulate everything
marty anything else you want to say
thank you guys tell a homie
it's a big year for all of us big here
is gonna [__] push forward i love
this community man it's changed my life
undoubtedly
so it just makes me feel even more
powerful like everybody's thoughts
everybody's wishes everybody's like
i love it's like a vortex where people
get inspired by us just pushing forward
with this [__] not giving a [__] just
going for it and then in turn
that help that makes them feel fired up
to go do it and then they they affect
the next person in the same way yeah
that's exactly what it is man
so thank you guys and keep [__] doing
it yeah whatever you're doing oh yeah
2022 [__] a [__] just go after
it and get it man 20 22. man it's going
to be a big [__] year i can yeah i
could see it
i'm excited
i'm excited those new year's resolutions
like i said circle back before we leave
set some small goals let's get the [__]
done set a monthly goal stuff you can
obtain in a few weeks get it done it's
that new car
maybe save up for it maybe put 100 bucks
a week away
anything that's working towards
something is [__] positive that's all
i gotta say
just try
all right 2022 just [__] try your
best
get it done love it that's it
guys
thank you so much for being here i will
see you next [__] year marty
why
as you're leaving school oh i haven't
drank soda since last year it's the
first i used to say that she has a kid i
haven't drink soda since last year
[__] [__] all right guys thank you
so much for watching thank you for being
here uh story time what's good giveaways
don't forget to hit us up have a best
day this has been the dopey junior
podcast we're here to talk about life
drugs problems accomplishments and
everything in between have a good have a
dope ass day have a good year
all right great
done
pretty high off that
are you ready
[Music]
perfect perfect
perfect
[Music]